there's a lot of people talking this
morning about whether or not
drew brees
is declining
given that he's only completing 64 of
his passes
uh compared to 74 in the last couple of
years his air yards are under five
when i think it's real simple
michael thomas needs a raise
michael thomas is already i think the
highest paid receiver uh maybe the andre
hawkins passed him
but um
yeah wait i mean that's it you know you
don't have wait that's not okay that's
not right is that right
no that's not right don't stack week one
when they play tampa bay anyway point
being
um
you know it's two weeks in i don't know
if there's any grand takeaways to you
know to sign the drew brees right now
bottom line is he missed michael thomas
last night they had the ball for like 23
minutes i'm not buying into this drew
like i'm not saying he's gonna stay at
that level forever and sometimes they do
fall off a cliff sometimes the decline
is sudden i don't think this we're
talking we're looking at the demise of
drew brees after two too soon for that
don't you think that's that's the key
that's the key word might you said
demise is it the the demise of drew
brees no
is he on the decline probably
right i mean you you probably are but he
had so much
he had so much to kind of fall from
i mean it's like this is one of great
all-time quarterbacks so
if you put it in in
madden terms another madden reference
get in as many as we can on brother from
another so in madden terms let's say
he's a 97 or a 98 and he drops down to a
90 or an 89 still a really good
quarterback he's just not at the level
he was before and there aren't many guys
at his age
who can say i'm maintaining the level
that i had five years ago tom brady's
trying but we'll see if tom brady and
i've always believed you know how i feel
about brady i've always believed that
brady would be able to pull it off we'll
we'll see we'll see
last year not a great year for brady at
age 42
but still the best age 42 season we've
seen in in nfl history because most guys
don't make it that far
well i think it's the same thing i think
it's the same thing with with brees uh
the production is pretty good he's the
best quarterback they have on their
roster i know they signed jamison and
they got uh uh taysom hill and all this
stuff nah he's the best quarterback on
the roster still one of the top uh
quarterbacks in the league just not
top five magic still not top five
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports